[Music]
you know there are only a few corporate
chains whose honor and dignity i will
defend to my dying breath bass
bass pro shops is one arby's is another
and rounding out the trio
is that realm of culinary delight known
as cracker barrel um i i maintain that
you simply will not find a better
meatloaf dish with three sides for under
12
anywhere in the world i dare you to try
maybe it's maybe a low bar but still
also across the entire american
southeast there are like 46 cracker
barrels per square
mile it's become such a part of the
landscape that you either develop an
affection for it or you become
deeply depressed and i have chosen
affection in this case and so
it may be partly because of this deep
affection that i take personally the
recent efforts by some on the left to
turn cracker barrel racist
this is one of the weirder trends among
progressive race hustlers
they notice a lot of white people
congregating in buildings um in these
cracker barrel buildings disappearing
inside for hours at a time
re-emerging with a fatter stomach and
carrying a scented candle and a bag of
hard candy from the gift shop
and they figure that something sinister
must be happening inside
something racist that's why a few months
ago cracker barrel you may remember made
headlines because there was a quote
noose hanging from the ceiling in one of
their restaurants and this sparked
outrage until it was discovered
that the noose was actually not a noose
but the cord of an antique soldering
iron
but no worries said the media you know
they simply changed their headlines and
reported that a quote here's cnn's
phrasing a quote
noose-like cord was found in a cracker
barrel
yes if you can't get away with calling
it a noose just call it noose like
and the great thing is that literally
any rope string or cord
can be called noose like
now if you thought that would be the
most desperate attempt to racistify
cracker barrel um you were wrong
yesterday the chain was trending again
this time due to a meme posted by some
random twitter account
which makes the following claim this is
this is the claim
cracker was a slang term for whip that's
why blacks called whites crackers from
the crack of the whip
a cracker barrel is a barrel that held
the whips for sale at the country store
you see the whip going from the r to the
k in the logo
racism in your face now this claim that
cracker barrel was named after barrels
of whips
sold at the country store for plantation
owners to use on their slaves
this claim was amplified and repeated
and immediately unquestionably accepted
by thousands of people
sophia nelson who's a self-described
self-described award-winning journalist
retweeted this claim with the caption
heavyside
i really like cracker barrel but now
that i see this and i get it
i sadly no longer can eat there and she
passed this along
to her 74 000 followers this is what
award-winning journalists do now
they see a meme accept it absolutely and
on face value and then
promptly spread it as a fact to the
public
the backlash was so intense that uh
eventually cracker barrel actually had
to issue a statement
addressing it and denying
the racist origins of their name now
an intelligent person uh of which there
are there is a
dwindling supply in this country upon
hearing this claim about
barrels of whips might immediately
suspect that something isn't right first
of all
why would you sell whips in a barrel of
all things
wouldn't they get tangled isn't that the
most
impractical way to sell whips but you
can go to lowe's or home depot and find
all kinds of ropes and cords for sale
news like items cnn would say uh and and
what you'll find is that they're all
hanging or or placed neatly on
shelves if you walk into a lowe's and
say excuse me can you point me to your
barrel of ropes they're going to look at
you like you're insane
the other problem with the claim is that
it's completely made up
maybe that's the main problem with it is
that it's just completely totally
made up this is a thing that somebody on
the internet simply
invented out of whole cloth and posted
there is zero
truth to it as it turns out and
shockingly even snopes
did a fact check on this um the term
cracker barrel comes from literal
barrels of crackers
that used to be sold at country stores
now
a barrel of crackers seems itself sort
of impractical and unsanitary
um but you know this was a different
time people back in those days thought
nothing of sticking their hand into a
huge
barrel and pulling out a wad of crackers
and then they'd buy the handful of
crackers for a nickel or whatever it was
and
and that's where the name comes from the
cracker barrel origin story that went
viral
yesterday was essentially a conspiracy
theory and this is what we have to
understand
this is a conspiracy theory and this is
how left-wing conspiracy theories often
work
we know about the conspiracy theories on
the right q anon sandy hook trutherism
and so on
we hear plenty about those but the left
has its own
um just just they just look a little
different and are built on different
background assumptions
the most basic background assumption for
the left-wing conspiracy theory is that
everything is racist
every institution is racist and racism
that is bigotry by white people against
non-white people specifically
is embedded into everything in our
culture see that's conspiracy theories
are all about
finding patterns where they don't exist
or finding patterns where they do exist
and then inventing extravagant and
fantastical explanations for those
patterns
this happens on both sides of the aisle
it is
very far from an exclusively right-wing
phenomenon claiming that the cracker
barrel logo is a racist
dog whistle from a store with mysterious
new nooses hanging in its gift shop
is a conspiracy theory every bit as
ridiculous and invented as the claim
that a pizza shop in dc
is the staging ground for a child sex
trafficking ring
the only difference again is the
background assumption that goes into it
and so cracker barrel is not cancelled
it will never be canceled on that one
as long as it keeps serving that
delicious meatloaf but
the conspiracy theorists smearing its
good name are
absolutely cancelled well i hope you
enjoyed that clip from the matt wall
show if you did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content